[Music]
[Applause]
buddy Ross Tucker hosts the Ross Tucker
football podcast be found on social
media at Ros Tucker NFL he's on the call
for the Titans and the Steelers tonight
on Westwood one and he's got that battle
between Ohio State and ruter Saturday
for CBS Ross good morning how much tape
of will Levis have you seen and what do
you think of
him morning Dan uh first of all before I
answer the the will Levis question to
your point about your
Mercedes I only floss the night before
I'm going to the dentist that's that's
the only time I floss the night before
I'm going to the dentist same same logic
and reasoning I think U well it's funny
the Levis thing is funny because you
know I live in central Pennsylvania so I
follow Penn State really closely and he
was showing Clifford's backup for like
three years at Penn State and I talked
to some of the Penn State coaches when
they were having a competition between
sha Clifford and Tommy Stevens and they
said if you came to our practice the guy
that you'd say who is that is Will Levis
he looks like Troy Aman I mean he is
built exactly the way you want a
quarterback to be built he's got a gun
for an arm he's a good runner obviously
went to Kentucky and had a bunch of
success but it's wild I mean Dan he
threw four touchdown passes on Sunday
the Titans had three touchdown passes
the first seven games the first seven
weeks of the Season he threw three
touchdown passes over 30 yards that's as
many as like Patrick Mahomes and Joe
burrow combined this year it's really
just a wild thing now this will be a
little bit different right now there's
some tape out on them now it's on the
road in Pittsburgh short week and I
don't I don't love his matchup with the
offensive tackles against High Smith and
TJ watt I'll be really curious to see
how this game goes for Levis because we
see this right Dan we see a guy the
first time they start it goes really
well everybody gets excited and then the
next game not so much I'll be curious to
see if he can sustain that performance
from Sunday because it was really
impressive okay but if you're a defense
what are you taking away from that first
tape with Will Levis that will help you
tonight you're taking away that they're
going to run a lot of play action with
him and you can't fall for it because
that's really what happened right I mean
the Falcons thought okay Levis is
starting rookie quarterback they're
gonna run the ball a lot the Falcons
were all geeked up to stop the run and
so the the Titans had a great game plan
fake the Run everybody's worried about
Derrik Henry throw it deep to Hopkins
and he cashed in three different times
the Steelers will be a little bit more
savvy than that they'll be a little bit
more aware that the I mean I think it
was like 50% play action passes on
Sunday Dan 50% that is really really
high the Steelers will not be fooled
like the Falcons were Paulie maintains
this was a good week for the
Raiders what do you think yeah I heard
that I heard you guys going back and
forth on that a little bit um I think
longterm it's probably a good week for
the Raiders because things were not
going in the right direction
with Josh McDaniels and Dave Ziggler but
man you look at the money that Mark
Davis and who cares if you're a Raiders
fans it's not your money but the money
he has to pay Gruden's coaching staff
the money he has to pay now McDaniel's
coaching staff it's just such a shame
Dan I mean if you remember two years ago
only two years ago okay Gruden gets
fired because or resigns whatever
because of those emails Henry rugs their
first round pick has that horrible car
accident Damon Arnett has his issue Rich
basa and may but basa was the coach they
won all those close games Dan they go to
the playoffs if you remember they're in
the Red Zone in that wild card game
against the Bengals they almost won the
game the Bengals go on to beat Tennessee
beat Kansas City Bengals go to the Super
Bowl all he had to do Dan was give Basia
like a three-year deal and it could have
been a one-year trial period just see if
he can continue that coach he can
continue that momentum it was a small
sample size obviously but it the only
sample size bace has as a head coach was
fantastic but honestly he thought he was
too good for bace well he's just a
special teams coach I need to get a
bigger name I need to get a bellich guy
I need to get McDaniels so you know
Careful What You Wish For What Mark
Davis this is all his doing because he
thought he and the Raiders were too good
for Basia he should make maybe you
should try to bring him back try to turn
around the karma for what happened yeah
but you mentioned that if you're a
Raider fan you don't care what they're
paying but it could impact what you're
going to pay this next guy because you
are paying guden and you're paying Josh
McDaniels and if you go let's see if we
can get the big ticket item Jim Harbaugh
to be interested in this well what's
Harbaugh going to cost you $15 million a
year is he going to want a 10year deal
for 150 you know the fact that you're
paying these other guys might you might
had paus and trying to you know bring in
somebody a big big item that's that's a
good point but maybe they don't need to
bring in like a big name or like a
harball like that right maybe they just
bring in like the next Shane stien or
the next demo Ryan or the next young guy
that you know has shown some promise as
a coordinator I always think it's weird
too like did they really need to give
Josh
McDaniels like a six-year contract Dan
for for whatever is $65 million dollar a
year you know where else was he going to
go I I think the negotiating for coaches
contracts are crazy it because couldn't
they have gotten somebody else who's
done a good job like I right now on your
show I will be the next head coach of
the Las Vegas Raiders for 2 million a
year six year you know what I'll do
fouryear contract four-year contract 2
million a year Mark Davis I will take
that job
okay what if they say 1.9
million yep still doing it okay all
right man you're a tough
negotiator talking to Ross Tucker he'll
be at the game tonight working for
Westwood One the Titans and the Steelers
I saw this on pro football talk with
Mike Florio he floated this idea floated
because he had been told something that
could you see the commanders trading for
Bill bellich and let bellich come in and
run the Commanders
yes I could see it and I kind of love it
I'll tell you why it it gives craft and
the Patriots and out I mean Dan they're
the worst team in the AFC they're the
only team in the AFC that doesn't have
at least three wins they're two and six
so right now Robert Craft is probably
scratching his head trying to figure out
how they can move on in a somewhat
palatable way right amicable way if
you're Josh Harris so the New England
part of it I think is pretty obvious if
you're Josh Harris it's a little bit
different because belich che's up there
in years but man you want to talk about
changing the culture changing the
identity changing how people view the
Commander's franchise you bring in
arguably the best head coach of all time
certainly one of the best coaches of
whole time I think it just gives Josh
Harris and the commanders instant
credibility and at a minimum you would
think the bellich and I know things
haven't gone well in New England the
last couple years but he'd be able to
get that organization back on the right
track I kind of love it for both sides I
gotta be honest with you Vince Lombardi
ended his career with Washington after
leaving Green Bay he I think went into
to be the GM um we've been talking about
this Julian Edelman or Randy Moss's
career Paulie likes the fact and Satan
does too that Edelman
what he's done with the Super Bowls he's
got three of them he was a Super Bowl
MVP not a Hall of Famer um and you have
Randy Moss who would you what
career yeah I mean Randy Moss is
considered one of the alltime great and
we're not talking about any issues off
the field or any incidents just what
they did inside the White Lines well no
and we're not even talking about Edelman
you know with steroids you know because
like Randy Moss has a you know has some
off the field issues we're just just
talking about on the field football so I
have I have the perfect answer to this
okay and and and this is how I look at
things now who wants to guess who wants
to guess what Ross Tucker is going to
say does he say Edelman or Randy Moss
Tod I think he's gonna say Randy Moss
all right Satan Randy Moss all right
Marvin Edelman
Paulie Moss I'm gonna say Edelman Ross
your your answer is my answer is if I
was going to choose to live my life
for the rest of my life with my family
and everything in Boston or the New
England area right like then it's
Edelman for sure whereas Randy Moss
doesn't really have that so people don't
look at it right I know you guys are
just talking about what they did on the
field but we're I'm talking about like
the next 40 50 years of their
life I would rather be Edelman living in
New England in Boston than Randy Moss
living anywhere else does that make
sense I mean Edelman yeah you be loved I
get that I'm talking about you have
their resume which resume do you want
not where you live yeah um I I would
want I would want Edelman I would want
the Super Bowls okay yeah I mean listen
I think what R Randy Moss is obviously a
better player unbelievable player I
think the chance to win a Superbowl that
experience Randy Moss never got to
experience that Edelman got to
experience that three typ the whole
thing the ring ceremony the parade that
that feeling of a I'm sure it's great to
be a Hall of Famer and I'm sure you take
so much pride in that but edelman's
gonna be like you know get that red
jacket for being in the Patriots Ring of
Honor which is kind of similar right it
would be Edelman
because no matter what you accomplish as
an individual it's never as special as a
group accomplishment with another group
of people for a common goal that you
come together and Achieve I mean I still
think about my high school championship
junior year of high school and those
guys all the time more than I think
about anything individually I did in the
NFL or anything safe travels to
Pittsburgh thank you really appreciate
it all right that's Ross Tucker Westwood
One he'll be on the sidelines tonight
for that call and then uh Saturday for
CBS he's got Ohio State and ruter